[Musique]
là où il n'y a pas de justice il n'y a
pas de paix
ou ça n'a pas justice n'a pointé
cette phrase les souvent scandé dans
toutes les manifestations dans toute
l'immobilisation auquel j'ai participé
les quatre dernières années
gilet jaune marche contre la vie chère
mobilisation pour plus de justice
sociale et environnementale marche pour
le climat pour des politiques publiques
qui soient à la hauteur des enjeux de
l'urgence climatique
mobilisation auprès de la communauté
lgbtqia+ marche blanche marche contre le
patriarcat
souvent on me dit mais tu te disperses
aller comme ça dans toutes les
manifestations et que il y a rien de
commun mais toutes ces manifestations
tous ces mobilisations ont
fondamentalement quelque chose de commun
une colère une colère liée aux
injustices répétées une colère de ne
pouvoir faire changer les choses ne
pouvoir faire changer les regards de
ceux qui sont postes de pouvoir dans les
lieux de décision de ceux qui sont dans
les médias et ceux qui sont en haut de
la pyramide
il relativise et disent mais enfin on
n'est pas si mal en France la France
c'est le pays des droits de l'homme la
France c'est le pays des possibles le
pays des libertés et puis aller voir
ailleurs vous verrez si c'est mieux
c'est ainsi qu'ils iront à des parents
qui vont demander
des moyens beaucoup plus adaptés dans
des écoles notamment de banlieue mais
enfin vos enfants vont à l'école
imaginez si vous étiez dans votre pays
d'origine
ce sont ceux-là même qui vont dire aux
femmes qui militent pour l'égalité
salariale mais de quoi tu te plains tu
as le droit de travailler tu touches ton
salaire tu as pas besoin de Marie etc on
est quand même pas en Iran là en France
effectivement tout ça c'est écorche un
peu l'image qu'on aurait envie de se
faire d'une France égalitaire d'une
France et liberté d'une France où les
privilèges auraient été abolis en 1792
mais si on croit encore à cette image
d'Épinal c'est qu'on accepte de
simplifier une réalité complexe
on simplifie en invisibilise le vécu de
trop nombreuses personnes qui subissent
au quotidien des agressions des
discriminations en lien avec leur
identité leur identité sociale leur
genre leur phénotype leur morphologie
leur lieu d'origine
quand on accepte ça
quand on accepte de se dire que c'est
pas si grave on soutient un système qui
s'appuie sur des valeurs capitalistes
d'individualisme de domination et du
patriarcat
moi j'aimerais aujourd'hui vous inviter
à vous enlever cette croyance qu'on vit
dans une société décente à essayer de
plonger et essayer d'accepter que notre
société est une société qui bien trop
souvent humilie abîme celles et ceux qui
sont hors de la norme
on nous fait croire qu'il y a une
recette toute faite pour réussir il
suffit d'aller à l'école de faire des
efforts de bien travailler de suivre
toutes les règles et ça devrait aller il
y a pas de raison d'échouer mais c'est
oublier clairement la reproduction
sociale qui est toujours trop présente
dans notre société il n'y a qu'à voir la
sur-représentation des enfants
d'ouvriers et d'agriculteurs dans les
lycées professionnels dans les
décrocheurs dans les chez les invisibles
la sur-représentation des enfants de
cadres de médecins dans les filières
d'excellence
les statistiques disent que quand son
père a fait Sciences Po on a 77 fois
plus de chances d'être à Sciences Po
une dernière étude de l'OCDE nous dit
qu'en France il faut cette génération
pour qu'une personne
née dans un milieu modeste atteignent le
niveau de revenus moyens du pays cette
génération quand je regarde cette
génération derrière moi du côté de ma
mère je vois à Nathalie jenade campagne
marie-louise-toi net des femmes sans nom
parce que des femmes esclaves
et dans une société post-coloniale on ne
peut pas nier que les discriminations et
les inégalités sont très présentes
en 2021 les forces de l'ordre ont
enregistré 12500 infractions
sur des faits de xénophobie à la
religion
être femme noir de quartier populaire
augmente les risques de subir au long de
sa vie des discriminations pour se loger
pour travailler avec un salaire décent
en fonction de ses capacités pour
accompagner convenablement son enfant
et ça quand on est femme quand on vit
dans ces conditions on transmet cette
incapacité que l'environnement que le
système fait peser sur nous le transmet
à nos enfants
en interviewise l'expérience d'être
subalterne et non seulement on le
partage et on le transmet à ses enfants
en le transmet aussi à ceux qui sont
autour de nous parce que si dans mon
environnement personne ne réussit à quoi
bon faire des efforts
qui je suis moi pour y arriver
quand on n'a pas d'exemple de réussite
devant nous en fait on intériorise ces
croyances limitantes on croit que ça
fait partie de nous de notre identité
que de ne pas réussir que de ne pas
monter le palier de la censure sociale
et tout ça c'est intériorisation avec
l'épigénétique ça va renforcer les
assignations dominantes les assignations
géographiques les assignations sociales
les assignations genrées
et finalement
bien le système parce qu'il permet de
tenir puisqu'il culpabilise il fait
porter la charge d'un individu
pourquoi je suis plutôt à l'aise pour
parler de ces dynamiques parce qu'il y a
plusieurs titres je suis concernée je
vais vous dire d'où je parle
je suis une femme de 40 ans noir
française d'outre-mer
je suis enfant d'agriculteur modeste
je suis mère célibataire
je suis neuro atypique
je suis valide et je suis diplômé d'une
grande école
et là vous allez avoir une encre qui va
s'allumer en disant ça va être tout s'en
sortir quand même donc finalement c'est
possible et diplômée d'une grande école
mais en fait je suis l'arbre qui cache
la forêt
celles et ceux qui réussissent à faire
exploser les plafonds de verre en fait
nos parcours ils sont surexploités et
surexposés par le système on sert de
caution pour faire croire qu'il existe
de la mobilité sociale
on sert de caution pour délégitimer la
violence la colère qui arrive la révolte
qui arrive chez les gens qui disent mais
ce système il me bloque
on sert de caution à notre insu
et pourtant
pour une personne racisée qui présente
un JT sur une grande chaîne nationale
combien de personnes racisées dans ces
mêmes locaux qui sont relégués aux
toilettes ou à vider la corbeille à
papier
pour une femme
cadre qui accède un salaire décent en
fonction de ses capacités de son
expérience
combien de femmes travaillent au
quotidien et reste pauvre combien de
femmes travaillent s'épuisent sont
invisibles dans leur travail et ne sont
pas en capacité
de faire élever leur enfant comme elles
aiment le faire
17% de salaire en moins pour les femmes
par rapport à des hommes à temps de
travail et équivalent
or on sait que les femmes dans des
foyers violents restent souvent
faute d'indépendance financière
en France en 2021
122 femmes ont été tuées par leur ex ou
par leur compagnons
85% des morts violentes au sein du
couple ce sont des hommes qui tuent les
femmes
des femmes souvent incapables de partir
par un système patriarcal qui les
enferme
et ces vérités en fait elles sont
visibles comme le nez au milieu du
visage mais ceux et celles qui sont en
haut de la pyramide qui tiennent les
règles les reines du pouvoir qui sont
dans les lieux de décision qui sont dans
les médias qui sont dans le monde
économique ils font comme si ça
n'existait pas il crée la norme à leur
image une homme dominante qui puisse et
qui écrase
et ils utilisent en fait tous les moyens
à leur disposition pour diffuser leur
norme et pour faire oublier la réalité
de ce qui se passe
et quand ça devient trop visible
qu'est-ce qui se passe mais en fait ils
vont inverser le statut de victime
et on va arriver sur le mode ou un One
qui va être activé face au lutte
intersectionnelles on va entendre
attention le walking
face au lutte des coloniales quel
concept on invente le racisme anti-blanc
face au mouvement MiTo qu'est-ce qui se
passe bon on a toute la fragilité de
l'homme qui remonte avec le oh mais pas
tous les hommes
pour certains ça reste encore un peu
abstrait donc moi je vais vous inviter
si vous le voulez bien à venir dans
certaines de mes expériences
personnelles
à l'école d'abord on parcours scolaire
en terminale le conseiller d'orientation
me dit vous avez un dossier scolaire qui
est pas trop mal mais là d'où vous venez
et vu ce que font vos parents une fac
d'histoire ou de droite et ira très bien
vous en connaissez beaucoup vous des
enfants d'ingénieurs de médecins en
Terminale S option maths avec 17 de
moyenne à qui on proposerait
tout de même chose pour Paris sans
étudiant en première année
trois enfants d'ouvriers d'agriculteurs
j'en fais partie une personne non
blanche racisée moi
les étudiants qui me disent mais
vraiment droit dans les yeux en disant
mais
tu fais là tu as aucune légitimité être
parmi nous tu prends la place en étant
là de personnes qui comme nom était
éduquées depuis des générations à faire
partie de l'élite et être dans ses
écoles et à suivre ses études là
ce à quoi fera écho l'attitude de
certains professeurs qui pendant toute
l'année me feront sentir que je ne suis
qu'une ultra marine une Française de la
périphérie qui me relaera et massignera
à cette place périphérique et marginale
un peu comme pour me faire payer ma
présomption d'appartenir à ce monde dont
je n'ai pas les codes et auquel je
n'étais pas destiné
le monde professionnel
dernièrement un rendez-vous un homme de
type HSBC qui arrive et qui voit ma
jeune stagiaire blonde pimpante aux yeux
bleus et qui arrive qui lui sert la main
oui bonjour je suis content de vous
rencontrer vraiment heureux de
collaborer avec vous nos échanges
étaient hyper intéressants etc je suis
de l'autre côté du bureau il me calcule
pas j'arrive chez bonjour monsieur je
suis Martin Yuri c'est avec moi que vous
avez rendez-vous et j'ai censuré ce qui
s'est passé dans ma tête
alors
dans la vie de tous les jours j'ai chez
le médecin
cabinet médical que je ne connais pas la
secrétaire médicale qui me demande la
carte CMU et à la personne juste après
moi à quelle mutuelle est-ce que vous
êtes
un peu de sexisme c'est pas mal aussi
mais sexy je marche dans la rue et
derrière moi un groupe d'hommes qui
parle assez fort exprès pour que
j'entends là mais qui ose pas me
dépasser et qui me fait waouh de cette
fille j'aimerais vraiment la chevaucher
franchement celui qui la chevauche il
doit avoir beaucoup de chance je me suis
pas retourné j'ai continué
un peu de racisme
la ligne 4 métro parisien
Saint-Germain-des-Prés là où je devais
aller parce que sur ce point était dans
les beaux quartiers
des contrôleurs qui arrivent qui
traversent tout le wagon qui se plante
devant moi et qui disent ton titre de
transport je lève la tête de mon livre
et j'en fais bonjour messieurs il y a un
problème ouais c'est bon fais pas ta
maline les gens comme toi on les connaît
et là je regarde je film en fait aussi
j'ai le droit je suis française il me
toise moi et ma maman mais regarde dès
vous vous êtes française vous êtes
français sur le papier
à Nice il y a 35 ans mes sœur et moi on
était sur la plage avec mes parents une
dame vient et nous dit mais enfin cette
plage elle est interdit au port
dans ma mémoire d'enfant elle avait dit
qu'elle était interdite au chien j'en ai
reparlé à ma maman il y a deux jours
elle me fait non
elle nous a bien dit que c'est interdit
au port 35 ans plus tard
ma mère avait encore des larmes de
colère
et effectivement avec ses agressions
perpétuelles ces humiliations répétées
ces injustices je peux dire aujourd'hui
que je suis une femme en colère
je veux dire aujourd'hui que je suis une
femme en colère et que je comprends ce
qui manifeste cette colère et pour qui
elle explose dans la violence des mots
et des corps
pour moi c'est violent elle est
intérieure
en général ça me prend ça me gave ça ça
me remplit et la stratégie elle a
toujours été la même c'est un moment mon
cerveau qui vient ma tête qui dit au
cœur et au corps c'est trop pour vous je
prends le relais j'allais chercher
j'essaie de comprendre ce qui se passe
je reviens vous chercher et là sans
suite toute une période où je lis
beaucoup je me renseigne j'essaie de
mettre des mots des concepts et c'est
comprendre ce qui se passe essayez de me
dire mais en fait il doit y avoir un
sens à tout ça je fais des formations
pour essayer d'avoir des outils pour
avoir des outils pour ne plus subir et
pour trouver la manière la plus saine la
plus durable de faire bouger les choses
mais je comprends en fait que ce soit
pas donné à tout le monde parce que
l'investissement la charge financière en
énergie en temps elle est juste énorme
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui avec
d'autres je travaille en fait à
construire des outils de transformation
individuels et collectifs
pour aider celles et ceux qui subissent
des oppressions
avoir des clés de compréhension
pour créer des espaces
ou six personnes seront en sécurité et
pour
prendre contact avec leur gaillard leur
potentiel où ils pourront soutier et
entrer en lutte et en résistance parce
que ce qu'on le veuille ou pas la seule
façon de changer les choses ça va être
de créer un rapport de force
si on veut repenser notre manière de
faire société son veut repenser de
manière d'habiter le territoire
si on veut repenser notre manière
d'habiter la terre et de d'utiliser les
ressources on n'a pas d'autre chose que
de faire basculer les normes pour que
les normes sociales ne soient plus les
nombres de domination mais qu'elle soit
d'énormes qui soient équitables juste
durable représentative
aussi
je vais vous demander
de quel côté de la ligne vous situez
vous
en fonction des nombreuses composants de
votre identité
à quel moment
êtes-vous oppresseur
êtes-vous voilier
êtes-vous opprimé
c'est une invitation réelle à checker
vos privilèges et ensuite à agir
ça peut se faire de différentes manières
avec ce qui est le plus juste pour vous
ça peut être aller à la rencontre de ces
groupes de ces personnes que vous savez
subir des oppressions pour essayer de
comprendre son vécu et lui dire oui je
te crois et je t'écoute je t'entends ça
peut être lire ça peut être explorer les
écrits de Bruno Latour
des subalterne te disent des communs de
l'éthique du Caire
changer de cette lecture dominante qui
nous dessine le monde en les bons et les
méchants
vous pouvez aussi agir au quotidien
donc quelle situation avez-vous été des
témoins passifs à quel moment tous les
rendez-vous des choses en disant mais
finalement tout le monde fait ça
et si vous ne le faites pas
faites-le pour vos enfants
parce que le monde les privilèges qui
vous permet de tenir est un monde qui va
s'écrouler
parce qu'en tant que parents à chaque
coup pris par mes enfants je répliquerai
et nous sommes nombreux à le faire et
face à vos enfants qui ne pourront plus
s'accrocher à leur privilèges pour tenir
se tiendront debout nos enfants nos
enfants se tiendront debout face à vos
enfants fier conscient de leur place ils
viendront revendiquer il viendront
récupérer leur juste part de dignité de
respect de liberté de démonité
et n'oubliez pas où ça n'a point justice
n'a point la paix merci